just when we thought we were getting a
little bit of relief from high gas
prices the cost of filling up your tank
back up again Victoria Saha explains how
this is continuing to affect those of us
on the road
gas prices are continuing to rise again
and Las Vegas residents are particularly
feeling the pain at the pump causing
many drivers to question how often
they're hitting the road things get
worse I could definitely see myself
having to to stop Adam Johnston is a
lift driver
but driving lately has become a daunting
task because of gas prices soaring again
I'm probably taking home maybe uh 120 to
150 something like that
um but still a big big chunk of the
bottom line is taken out
um drives four days a week and every day
it cost him more than 50. to fill up my
biggest fear is that prices continue to
climb and we're inching closer to that
as my photographer and I were driving
around we saw prices as high as 585 a
gallon near Durango and Flamingo
according to gasbuddies gas prices
dropped to 17.5 cents a gallon
nationally but why aren't we seeing much
of a change here Cara green with Western
State petroleum explains Nevada
primarily is getting their petroleum
Diesel from Utah and but also in Las
Vegas mostly from La based refineries
price is so unpredictable miles Reynolds
who owns Sport Court in Las Vegas says
it's affecting his projects around the
valley we have to be a lot more
strategic on how we schedule and and
alleviating having to come back to
projects his team spends more than 300 a
week when going back and forth to
project sites Victoria Saha 8 News Now
Gas Buddies tells us Refinery issues
leading to supply challenges a big
factor in the unstable gas prices they
do expect this to continue for at least
a few more weeks